تنضموا الينا الان من الخرطوم اسامه ابو
بكر المسؤول الاعلامي للهلالي الاحمر
السوداني استاذ اسامه اهلا بك معنا ما
جديد الوضع الصحي والانساني في السودان
طبعا لا يزال الوضع الصحي في اسوا حالاته
والوضع الانسان بشكل عام باصلح حالاته
ندره
القطاع الماء والكهرباء حتى على المواطنين
قبل ما ندخل على وضعه المستشفيات
يؤثر سلبا ويزيد من تفاقم المعاناه كما
ذهب زميلي في اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر قبل قليل
المعاناه تتضاعف ويطلب احيانا وجود توصيف
دقيق يوصف حجم المعاناه
الان يعني الناس
فاضيه يعني لا لا تستطيع التصرف يعني من
ناحيه الذين عندهم استطاعه ولون نسبيه
بيطلعوا بيمزحوا خارج العاصمه الى القرى
المجاوره امنا وخضوءا وفي ناس بيطلعوا
بهذه يعني بيمزحوا الى اقصى الشمال لمدينه
وادي حلفا انتظارا
لعبور الحدود البريه لجمهوريه مصر العربيه
الدي احدا التقدس كبير جدا نحن عندنا في
الشماليه هناك
المتطوعين في منطقه حلفا بيقوموا باعمال
جيده جدا
في المناطق بتاعه
الانتظار الناس المنتظرين
العبور الى مصر طبعا حالتهم ماساويه جدا
لانه انعدام الغذاء الكافي لانه القدره
بتاعت مدينه حلفا ما مستعده كانت لاستقبال
الالاف ممكن تحصل اكثر من عشره او 13 او
14 الف شخص منتظر في المعبره للذهاب الى
مصر بخل
اساس سلبيه على المدينه المدينه فيها شح
في المياه سواء كانت المياه بتاعه
الاستخدام اليومي او حتى مياه الشرب
والغذاء يعني في جزر بتاعه مجاعه لا قدر
الله ممكن تحدث في هذه المدينه الحدوديه
نسبه تسمى
اضافه لكده
النزوح للاطراف المدينه الخرطوم خارجها
سواء الى من الناحيه الجنوبيه او من
الناحيه الشرقيه للعاصمه نفس الحكايه ولدت
معاناه كبيره جدا جدا هؤلاء النازحون هل
يذهبون الى اقاربهم ربما هل يجدون ماوى
لهم ام يعني هم يعني يفرون فقط من من
الاقتتال الحاصل
بيمشوا هناك بيمشوا بينزحوا للمناطق
المجاوره في الاقاربهم او حتى لو
اقارب
المجتمعات المحليه يعني متضامنه جدا مع
الوضع
وبحاول يهيئ لهم كلكم راحه يعني انا بعرف
عندنا معلومات بدينا من الاقاليم انه
الشباب المنطقه وحتى كبار المناطق اللي
بتستقبل ناجحين من العاصمه من العونه
الذاتي مع بعض بحاول ويكرمه الناس الجايين
ضيوف عندهم يعني بيتقاسموه معاهم
في يعني
صور جميله جدا وعظيمه جدا لتضامن الشعب
السوداني مع بعضه في هذه المحنه
نعم طيب ما هي اهم الاحتياجات ان كان
بالنسبه لهؤلاء النازحين او بالنسبه للذين
بقوا في ديارهم استاذ اسامه
بتولد الحاق بتولد بعض الامراض حتى نفسيا
يعني غير الدعم الصحي
البدني في الصحه النفسيه لانه الناس اول
مره في يعني في ناس اول مره في حياتهم
يعيشوا التجربه بتاعه النزوح الى الخارج
وهما معدنين يكاد يكونوا معدنين
بنفسه حل يعني خلفت اثار نفسيه عندهم
فالهلال الاحمر السوداني طبعا بدعم من
مجموعات الصليب والهلال الاحمر الموجوده
هنا ودعم اللجنه الدوليه للصليب جمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال احمد
اصلا في تدريب في الهلال الاحمر المستمر
في كوادر متخصصه في السايكو سوشل سبورت
اللي هو الدعم النفسي الاجتماعي للحالات
الزايده معظم الحالات اللي بتكون متاثره
بالحرب او الكوارث الطبيعيه الفئات الم
[موسيقى]
كنت معنا من الخرطوم
المزيج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات